policing Europe's borders and dealing
with crises just beyond them were key
issues to surface in the second day of
Commissioner designate hearings no to
fortress Europe was the message from the
Greek dimitris avramopoulos itemizing
first the threats an exploding
geopolitical environment a new terrorist
threat get us inside our cities the
answer to this challenges is definitely
not fortress Europe in the civil
liberties committee that will resonate
well but MEP is also wanted commitments
this year already three thousand persons
have died in the Mediterranean the only
way is to create legal and safe routes
to the EU for asylum seekers yep Addison
xicot are a protein allover Togolese
lavando see pops in katie's de que se
sepa Simmons's allicattt in Iberia Papa
COMESA may all on a toda grow grass
denied amusement and no miko bless you
and what about Schengen seen by many in
this chamber as a shining European
success Schengen is one of the greatest
achievements of European integration and
we have to maintain the absence of
controls at the internal borders two
floors up johannes hahn Austria's
Commissioner designate for neighborhood
and enlargement negotiations was feeling
questions on Ukraine in particular a
Ukrainian plan to devolve regional power
and sort out the conflict there an
excellent proposal that could contribute
also to a settlement of the ongoing
conflict and as for Russia Russia should
not underestimate news resolve to stand
by its principles but should also
understand that our neighbourhood policy
and the Eastern Partnership another
project designed at Russia's expense
also up morale chef kovitch moved
transport and space from
inter-institutional relations and
administration with a brief to develop
Europe's connectivity and space projects
and christos steliana des at
humanitarian aid and crisis management
among his tasks if he's confirmed to
boost the efficiency of Europe's
emergency response to disasters